hi leva you've been in the southern
charm universe i think as long as we've
been in this other charm universe
you've been around yeah i have
why join the show now seven seasons in
officially it came into my life as an
option and
i just was like i'm a little
uncomfortable with this but you know
let's do it
so we've known you over the years for
your little chiron your little lower
third that says
cameron's friend cameron's not around
this year so is it worth to
kind of almost switch places with her
yeah i mean i definitely wouldn't say
switch places but i definitely
um it's just weird if i thought okay
well this is great with each other all
the time
so i was expecting her to be there and
then last minute sort of things changed
but
i also respect her decisions katherine
told me that jason was having an affair
no no okay why would catherine say
something like that
because she's that's a full bold face
[ __ ] lie that's what i think it's
[ __ ] absurd too but
no imagine me that i had to tell someone
i was like
katherine that's some [ __ ] for me
you know as a friend i was like
come on march your butt over here and
handle this business
you just didn't want to deal with it and
that's that's half personality
she's not a confrontational girl and
also i think she was just
it wasn't serving her this year so yeah
i mean my thing was like come on
get out of here a little selfish lava
let's move on to talking about you and
who you are
i'm excited for people to meet you i
love your instagram biases
not for everyone what do you mean by not
for everyone
i definitely think i'm built differently
i'm going to shoot it to you direct
i expect it direct back i have a bit of
a temper
and i think that i can sometimes say
things people don't want to hear
i think it's good i want i would want
that
but not everybody's built like me you
know
so going into this experience what do
you want the viewers to know about you
i've known these people for so many
years so yeah
maybe you're looking at the trailer it
looks like i'm just jumping out here and
being like
you shut up you're white hear this
you're like i just come in with like
guns
and it really isn't that way i've known
these people for so many years
i have lived in the south for 20 years
but i also
have what is atypical in in southern
culture
you know i'm not always you know just
bless your heart
and pass the wine and the decor is
beautiful and let's just keep
you know i i want a real conversation i
want to get into it you know i genuinely
care about these people and i think
they're all good-hearted people and like
none of us are perfect
by far and we're just a pocket of
friends and this year was a difficult
year and
and i did my best so you know just give
me some grace and and i met i think the
biggest thing for me is like i don't
always say it right but i mean well you
know
let's talk about some of those
conversations you have at least judging
by the trailer
you work to hold katherine dennis
accountable this season
katherine you've spent your entire life
living in a bubble of
white privilege there's some things that
she did herself in her life and she had
asked my opinion about it
and i told her exactly how i felt about
it in a palatable way
because we know that catherine's
personality is one to just shut it down
and walk away that's her thing
i remembered who her first like her
personality and her triggers so i tried
to calmly
walk her through it i reminded her that
like you know
are you aware of your history like do
you really know your history and like
of all people do you know that just your
name triggers people
and it is what it is it's the cross you
bear there's a lot of trauma behind that
name but i think that you know
people are not responsible for their
history but they're responsible to know
their history
everybody says don't erase history okay
well let's not erase history let's
remember all of it the statue coming
down
it's like a huge statue and it is of
john c calhoun obviously an ancestor of
catherine's
he was a proud enslaver oh my god
[Music]
when it kind of got out in the news that
you guys were filming at that coming
down there was this conversation around
why would the show film this this feels
like they're taking advantage of the
moment what do you want people to take
away from
seeing that moment on tv and the
conversations you guys are going to have
around
the removal of the calhoun statue in
charleston
i don't expect everybody to know the
history of charleston but that statue
was on the same street
as the massacre of the emmanuel nine the
nine people that were killed in the
church
and it's not just the statue a statue
was built
as an overseer to slaves that statue is
built
so high and it looks down on what used
to be called boundary street that was a
street where if you cross that street we
can do whatever we want to
for that to still stand there on a
street where
nine people you know were massacred and
really essentially
someone was trying to start a race war
and charleston was big-hearted enough to
not do that
let's honor and get rid of this thing
let's move this away
and so it was either don't go or bring
the cameras with me it just
was what it was and you know we got lots
of comments about how we were dressed
well if i'm
meeting with the mayor i dress nicely
i'm a businesswoman the invitation
was not casual i didn't tell them i was
bringing cameras but you know
when i got there i was like hey can they
come with me this was something
happening
in your life whether the southern charm
cameras were going to be there or not
i was scheduled to film and i want to be
authentic about my life and it's not
easy
i want to take it back to your other
moment with catherine that we see in the
trailer the discussion about the
racially insensitive use
of a monkey emoji when i first saw
the monkey emoji i was just like what
the hell counts
like in my heart i know i'm the furthest
thing from
racism why were you the person to have
that conversation with catherine
i think at the time i mean i know she
has a black boyfriend now but
at the time i think i'm the only person
that she knew maybe that
was not white and i think that i've
always been really gracious with
catherine
and i have attempted to sort of be more
of like a big sister
mom place where i'm like listen like
smack on the hand not okay don't do that
again and so i think
in one sense being like i did this do
you think i'm racist like it really was
she didn't i think she didn't know how
to move forward with me
and she had texted me about our kids
hanging out and i was just like this is
weird i don't even know what i think
about you right now i i'd never
heard her say anything you know i found
horrendous like that and inexcusable but
i just
i was shell-shocked and and i think she
felt she knew she had to address it with
me
and on top of that i think i might have
been the one friend that
had the bandwidth for it and also
you know was a person of color that may
have had
the understanding she needed you know it
seems like it's gonna be a tough season
for her
to have to relive do you think she came
out the other side
growing and changing i hope so i don't
know
the action i wanted from her was not
banging a black eye but
maybe that's where that rests or maybe
she's doing some more reading or getting
more involved but
i don't know i i don't know i i just
know right now i stand where i stand
sort of like over here and i'm trying to
figure out
what's next with catherine i don't know
let's dig into all that because you come
into the show as the first
person of color on the show is that even
a thing that crossed your mind when you
signed on the dotted line like i have
this
thing to carry over the line or you just
signed up as leva
i just signed up as lava so that didn't
cross my mind at all it was just like
i'm friends with these people and okay
let's do this thing i was like thinking
i was gonna
run around in some pretty dresses and
bags and you know kiki with my friends
and laughs and stuff i did not expect
all the
heaviness did the call for racial
justice the reckoning with racism we're
having in the country
change at all how you viewed your kind
of role within the group within the show
it wasn't really a shift for me it was
just
i think what was happening in the world
was bleeding into
our friendship as it did in in
friendships across america
not toned after the fact that like okay
well we are in the south and
and i do find it difficult sometimes you
know when you're around these old
southern families and
there's a tremendous amount of affluence
but there's no acknowledgement that this
affluence was built on
atrocities committed towards another
group of people so i think being like
flippant about your
affluence is
gross how do you navigate though and
having to take on the burden of
everybody's questions
i think it's just at the end of the day
do you have the bandwidth for it or not
of course my husband is african-american
and his history and his
generational trauma and all that stuff
and uh is very different than mine
i think that i have a larger bandwidth
um for addressing topics like that
because i don't have
the generational trauma you know so i
can sit through and be like
this particular thing you did you know i
can speak about it with you calmly but
that's where the healing in america
starts
i don't want people to feel awkward
about things i want them to talk healing
isn't talking it's not about i hate you
you suck and all sorts
just right nothing it's about opening
the door
letting it like you can come into this
room i'll greet you but then you explore
the room yourself too
yeah and if you want my opinion of how
to explore or you need some guidance or
you might need me to hold your hand to
walk in
i have the bandwidth to do that nobody
owes you that
but if i'm your friend then it's it's a
good day for me and i'm not too stressed
out sure let's have a conversation
let me do my best to either you know
point you in the right direction overall
how do you feel about
your first season of southern charm i
think it was good it was a tough year
it was definitely out of my comfort zone
but it's a net positive which is
my you know motto for life like as long
as the net
is positive i'm good i i learnt a lot
you know i kind of love on them all
i'm hard on them i know i'm hard on them
i'm happy i did it i'm proud of us
because i think that like navigating
that was rough through covid
through you know the political temper
temperature of
the world like all the unknowns it was a
stressful year for all of us you know
so i'm proud of us for still being able
to be as authentic as possible
anything you're super excited for the
fans to see or anything you're dreading
having to relive yourself
dreading to relive all of it because i
feel like
i went somewhere i swore i was gonna
keep my composure and somehow
something just probably dreading all of
it but
at the end of the day it just it's all
real it wasn't easy to be that real
all the time it's not even easy in real
life to be that real all the time
but and it's fun i mean and it's a lot
right up to the finale the finale i was
like i'm going to sleep for two days